i'm not an experiment i'm a real human
being i will no longer allow this board
to make decisions for my family
regardless of your vote today i am
taking back full power and control by
withdrawing my healthy children out of
bps this is what i think about math
should kids have to wear masks at school
and for how long eighteen states require
kids some as young as two years old to
mask all day in school nine states have
banned school districts from requiring
masks in florida governor ron desantis
issued an executive order in july to
stop masked mandates writing that a
right to a normal education is
imperative to the growth and development
of our children and adolescents the
order came in part thanks to the
activism of parents like tina diskovic
we support parental choice and masking
always we believe a parent has the
ultimate authority the ultimate right
to the fundamental right to guide and
direct the upbringing the medical care
and the education of their children
dyskovic is a former member of the
brevard county school board and
co-founder of moms for liberty which has
160 chapters and more than 70 000
members nationwide and advocates for
parental rights she says mask
requirements drove parental engagement
like she's never seen before
any and all school board members that
vote yes on this mandate you're fired
masks work
and you know that
you refuse to and if you refuse to
understand that then you have no
business being on a school board
peaceful non-compliance will be our only
way forward
if they make the mass mandate where we
have to wear a mask i will not be
attending school and be doing flvs
because i cannot the bottom line is this
is wrong and it is illegal they showed
up to talk about the the concerns they
had for their individual child they
didn't really care or know about the
bigger picture but they knew their
student a mother of a deaf student spoke
parents of students with mrsa on their
face students with infantico on their
face
my son has a rash all around his mouth
and has for three months now
these parents are you know they're not
out for a crusade they're not on a big
mission they know their child they see
what's happening and so they come in
front of the school board to speak
dyskovic says compulsory masking caused
her 13 year old son to become obsessed
with the fear of getting sick a
psychological disorder known as
contamination ocd he's a very shy child
he's very much an introvert and as covid
was unfolding he really started
experiencing some mental health issues
he would hide behind the mask and i
think he would be unseen and he would
blend in and i was watching him closely
because the mental health issues were
escalating after the brevard county
school board voted to extend a mask
mandate several months before the
desantis executive order deskovich
pulled her son out of public school
i knew at that moment that i lost the
vote
that i couldn't keep him in our school
system i was a school board member of
our public schools it broke my heart to
pull him out of the district i shed a
few tears over it but it was necessary
for his health and well-being these
decisions that parents are making are
not necessarily
coming from a place of science it's
coming more from
just personal preference lisa gwyn is
the president of the florida chapter of
the american academy of pediatrics which
supports in-school mask mandates she
testified against the state of florida
in a lawsuit challenging desantis's
executive order but the judge in that
case sided with the governor stating in
his decision that the school boards
failed to prove that the state's mask
opt-out rules facilitate the spread of
govern 19 in schools this is why judges
should remain in the courtroom and not
in the clinic because everything that he
said is totally
wrong gwen acknowledges that covid19
poses a low risk of serious illness to
young children but says mask mandates
are necessary because they can still
spread the disease to adults
a lot of parents that i've heard talk
about this
feel like there's not a clear end in
sight and in the meantime their children
have to
wear these masks you know six seven
hours every day and that that has its
own costs in terms of being able to
communicate and socialize with peers
during a sensitive developmental period
how do you think about those trade-offs
well
have have these parents been inside a
classroom
okay if you ask teachers the same
question you know
kids are adjusting
that's what i love about working with
children is they're very resilient i
mean i i get that kids are compliant and
a lot of them are resilient but are
there any potential long-term
psychological effects that
parents should be concerned about
no not that we've seen i mean we look at
this you know
again we're advocates for for the health
and well-being of children we would
never make recommendations that weren't
vetted by experts and the aap continues
to recommend universal masking of kids
in in the classroom end of discussion in
early december the u.s surgeon general
announced that covet has had an
unprecedented impact on the mental
health of america's youth though it
didn't specifically cite mask wearing
the covet 19 pandemic further altered
their experiences at home school and in
the community it found because
compulsory all-day masking is a new
phenomenon there are no long-term
studies on its effect on childhood
mental health and development so are the
benefits worth the potential costs the
mass
we think of them as a completely benign
intervention but they are not jay
bhattacharya is a professor at stanford
and testified as an expert witness on
behalf of the state of florida in the
lawsuit over the governor's executive
order we essentially have reorganized
our society around the control of a
single infectious disease when in fact
health is plural health has many many
many inputs
public health is therefore going to be
complicated a public action that
benefits reduction of one disease might
hurt another disease we have to think
about these trade-offs all the time
bhattacharya pointed out an independent
study of florida school systems showed
no statistical differences in the case
rate between school districts that
required masks and those that didn't on
net mass are probably more harmful than
good in schools i don't believe that
there's any evidence that it actually
did much as far as coca-19 spread for
kids to wear masks the most widely cited
study in favor of mask mandates to use
data collected in north carolina schools
which the authors wrote about on the new
york times op-ed page but that study
suffered from a fundamental flaw as the
researchers admitted because north
carolina had a mass mandate for all k-12
schools we could not compare masked
schools to unmasked schools cdc director
rochelle wallensky recently shared a
graphic claiming masks in schools
reduced the likelihood of outbreaks by
three and a half times but that study
didn't even account for whether schools
were open during the period in question
attract outbreaks as opposed to cases
and didn't control for vaccination
status you can't learn anything about
the effects of school mask mandates from
the study jonathan ketchum a public
health economist at arizona state
university told david zwieg of the
atlantic
there's no randomized evidence at all on
masking children at zero like none no
high quality evidence in terms of
controlling disease spread that's what
leads to this kind of scientific
uncertainty bhattacharya who's an
informal advisor to desantis appeared
with the governor on a panel in march
that youtube removed from its platform
because they questioned the efficacy of
masking children which contradicted
guidance from the centers for disease
control i was stunned in that
environment to shut down debate like
youtube did or attempt to anyways um is
absolutely responsible the cdc has an
absolutely extreme position on mass it
recommends masking toddlers two and up
the world health organization recommends
against that says two to five don't mess
and for six to eleven it says think
about it very carefully because there
are some harms to them the dependencies
are the language development and other
developmental issues the european cdc in
particular says no masking at all below
12. but some parents of
immunocompromised children say that
desantis infringed on their liberties by
making it dangerous for them to come to
school
we have a child here in florida she was
suspended because she wouldn't wear a
mask what about her access you know it's
really unfortunate that we have to pick
and choose the vaccine is now available
and
n95 masks are available which have been
proven to keep out a portion of the
of the virus and so
if you are concerned about your child's
health you will probably want to make
sure they're vaccined if they're
high-risk and that they are very well
masked and that they have a well-fitting
mask but the blanket statement of
masking another person's child who may
have other issues is unacceptable and
some local officials say that desantis's
order amounts to executive overreach and
undermines local decision-making what do
you think about that is this setting a
bad precedent in terms of what a
governor can do it's an interesting
argument i believe in local control a
champion of low control and i think
education needs to have more local
control but
on this one issue
of government overreach
i think the role of government is to
protect its citizens and to defend their
individual liberty and if the governor
or a higher level of govern government
needs to step in to protect individuals
and their liberty and their ability to
raise their children and the way they
see fit i think that's the one instance
that it's okay
the florida department of education also
made available vouchers for any parent
looking for an alternative masking
policy then in place at their district
school the skovich supports this move
but says the state should do even more
to accommodate parents looking to
exercise choice
i think it's welcomed but there are a
lot of uh problems there so especially
here in florida one of the problems with
school choice is transportation the
ability to get from one school to
another if you're a family that can't
afford that that's not a choice for you
your school choice options have been
shut down for now florida has won its
standoff with the federal government
which dropped its cease and desist order
against the state for withholding funds
from school boards resisting desantis's
anti-mandate order no school districts
in florida currently have a mask mandate
in place
there's this tension that has come to
the fore between personal
choice and bodily autonomy and public
health
how do you think about those questions
especially when they come into conflict
okay if if we're going to just toss out
public health measures where do we start
where do we go from here
do we start allowing people to not wear
our seat belts if you want to do
whatever you want to do with you know in
the privacy of your own home
um that's one thing but if your behavior
affects somebody else
we as public health professionals have
to make those decisions to do what's
best for the for the entire community
not just for that one individual's
rights
long term this isn't about masks this
isn't about vaccine mandates this isn't
about coveted policies this is about the
role of the parents in a child's public
education it's fundamentally a
complicated thing and so to turn into a
morality tale of you must stop the
spread of this disease at the expense of
all else in life i think was an enormous
mistake
you